Alice: 火小一点
Alice: Lower the flame a bit.
Tasha: 火已经很小了
Tasha: The flame is already very low.
Alice: 你锅里是不是有油
Alice: Is there oil in the pot?
Alice: 哎不对
Alice: Oh, wait.
Alice: 有水
Alice: There's water.
Tasha: 没有我已经把水抽干了
Tasha: No, I've already dried the water.
Lucia: 这锅昨天是不是用过啊
Lucia: Was this pot used yesterday?
Tasha: 我靠这锅怎么这么倒
Tasha: Wow, why is this pot so messed up?
Tasha: 倒热怎么这么快
Tasha: Why does it heat up so fast?
Alice: 它比较薄
Alice: It's pretty thin.
Tasha: 拿一个那个小小小碟子来呗
Tasha: Can you get a small, small, small plate?
Tasha: 放这些饼
Tasha: Put these pancakes here.
Alice: 好
Alice: Okay.
Alice: 露西亚你就不用帮我热了吧
Alice: Lucia, you don't need to heat it for me.
Alice: 倒直接倒就行了
Alice: Just pour it directly.
Alice: 给你
Alice: Here you go.
Alice: 笑死了这个这个
Alice: This is hilarious.
Alice: 手机拍的好整齐你看
Alice: The phone took such neat pictures, look.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice: 像开会一样
Alice: It's like a meeting.
Tasha: 开会上交手机
Tasha: Hand in your phones during the meeting.
Tasha: 也不知道熟了没
Tasha: No idea if it's done.
Tasha: 外面都糊了
Tasha: It's burnt on the outside.
Alice: 没
Alice: No.
Alice: 这太短了时间
Alice: The time was too short.
Tasha: 那只能用小火煎了
Tasha: Then we can only fry it on low heat.
Tasha: 看看不清了都没关系
Tasha: It's okay if it looks unclear, no worries.
Alice: 你看这里面还爆浆呢
Alice: Look, it's still oozing inside.
Alice: 当然没熟
Alice: Of course, it's not done.
Alice: 看里面都不熟呢
Alice: See, it's still raw inside.
Tasha: 外面都已经这么黑了
Tasha: The outside is already so black.
Alice: 油有一点点大哈
Alice: The oil was a bit too much, huh.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Alice: 太厚了没关系没关系
Alice: It's too thick, it's okay, it's okay.
Alice: 把那个外面面的那个丢掉就行
Alice: Just throw away the outer layer.
Tasha: OK第一个饼先给杨老板吃
Tasha: OK, let's give the first pancake to Jake.
Tasha: 我这个锅怎么回事
Tasha: What's wrong with this pan?
Tasha: 太可怕了
Tasha: It's so terrible.
Alice: 你要不给弄开吧好
Alice: If you can't, just open it.
Tasha: 好你看看熟了没
Tasha: Okay, see if it's done.
Alice: 勉强
Alice: Barely.
Lucia: 哦sorry
Lucia: Oh, sorry.
Lucia: 我每次开门都会掉点东西下来
Lucia: Every time I open the door, something falls.
Alice: 小一点
Alice: A little smaller.
Tasha: 没事没事
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay.
Tasha: 我来把这个也也也剪开
Tasha: I'll cut this one open too.
Lucia: 我可以用一下那个灶吗
Lucia: Can I use that stove?
Tasha: 要要用微波炉
Tasha: Do you need to use the microwave?
Tasha: 呃呃好吧
Tasha: Uh, okay.
Tasha: 这个也可以了
Tasha: This one's done too.
Lucia: 微波炉打吗
Lucia: Should we microwave it?
Lucia: 不知道能不能打的透
Lucia: Not sure if it will heat through.
Lucia: 而且没事
Lucia: But it's fine.
Lucia: 就放在这吧
Lucia: Just leave it here.
Lucia: 然后大家再倒出来就好
Lucia: Then everyone can pour it out later.
Tasha: 啊这个锅太可怕了
Tasha: Ah, this pot is terrifying.
Alice: 露西亚你准备的是几个人的牛奶
Alice: Lucia, how much milk did you prepare for?
Lucia: 啊没事
Lucia: Ah, it's fine.
Lucia: 我们可以随便倒
Lucia: We can pour freely.
Alice: 啊因为我想喝凉的
Alice: Ah, because I want to drink it cold.
Lucia: 你想喝凉的有还有
Lucia: If you want it cold, we have more.
Alice: 啊对
Alice: Ah, okay.
Alice: 就是不用算我的量就可以了
Alice: So you don't have to count me in.
Lucia: 没事那就如果多了的话
Lucia: No worries, if there's too much.
Lucia: 大家一会多喝一点就好了哈哈
Lucia: Everyone can just drink a bit more later, haha.
Alice: 啊好
Alice: Ah, okay.
Alice: 可以可以
Alice: Sure, sure.
Lucia: 就是那个那个已经打开的我也没倒完
Lucia: That already opened one, I didn't finish it.
Lucia: 然后假如你不够喝
Lucia: So if you don't have enough,
Lucia: 你也可以打开那个新的
Lucia: You can open the new one.
Alice: 啊不用谢谢
Alice: Ah, no need, thanks.
Lucia: 没事没事
Lucia: No problem, no problem.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Lucia: 小心
Lucia: Be careful.
Alice: 这个我自己倒吧
Alice: I'll pour this myself.
Lucia: 啊好的
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Lucia: 然后我看看
Lucia: Let me see.
Lucia: 我们牛奶应该是要用杯子
Lucia: We should use cups for the milk.
Lucia: 我把剩下这几杯子都洗了
Lucia: I'll wash the remaining cups.
Alice: 我直接用碗了
Alice: I'll just use a bowl.
Lucia: 也可以哈哈
Lucia: That works too, haha.
Lucia: 这个任君选择
Lucia: It's up to you.
Lucia: 23234 那我们剩下有 4个
Lucia: 23234, so we have 4 left.
Lucia: 人都
Lucia: Everyone...
Alice: 给外国人一点震撼
Alice: Give the foreigners a shock.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 雨轩你要单喝纯牛奶吗
Lucia: Yuxuan, do you want plain milk?
Lucia: 还是你还喝你刚才的咖啡哦
Lucia: Or do you want your coffee from earlier?
Katrina:  用我就喝我自己这个就行
Katrina: I'll just drink my own.
Lucia: 好的好的
Lucia: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 那我们就三个杯子哎
Lucia: So we have three cups.
Lucia: 那牛奶可能稍微有点多
Lucia: The milk might be a bit too much.
Alice: 没事喝不完可以给我
Alice: No worries, if we can't finish it, I'll drink it.
Lucia: 啊可以哈哈你可以等他凉了再喝
Lucia: Ah, sure! You can drink it when it cools down.
Lucia: 或者我们多喝一点
Lucia: Or we can just drink a bit more.
Alice: 没事没事
Alice: No problem, no problem.
Alice: 我只是比较喜欢喝凉的
Alice: I just prefer drinking it cold.
Lucia: 我和薇薇多喝一点
Lucia: Tasha and I will drink a bit more.
Lucia: 因为那个靖康他好像也要喝咖啡
Lucia: Because Nicous also seems to want coffee.
Tasha: OK第二次做的是薄饼
Tasha: Okay, the second thing we're making is pancakes.
Alice: 你你那个离他远一点
Alice: You, you should stay a bit farther from it.
Alice: 因为怕熏到你的眼镜
Alice: Because it might smoke your glasses.
Tasha: 颠勺颠勺
Tasha: Flip the pan, flip the pan.
Alice: 哎哎小心点小心点啊
Alice: Hey, hey, be careful, be careful!
Tasha: 我靠太可怕了
Tasha: Oh my god, this is scary.
Tasha: 熟了吗熟了好像
Tasha: Is it done? Seems like it.
Alice: 哎小心点怎么了
Alice: Hey, be careful, what happened?
Alice: 怎么了
Alice: What happened?
Tasha: 没事
Tasha: It's fine.
Alice: 咋了我看看
Alice: What is it? Let me see.
Tasha: 我溅油了
Tasha: I got splashed by oil.
Tasha: 这真是一个脾气不好的锅
Tasha: This is really a bad-tempered pan.
Alice: 可以等油没那么热的时候就放进去
Alice: You can put it in when the oil isn't so hot.
Tasha: 我关小火了他还是崩了
Tasha: I turned down the heat, but it still splashed.
Alice: 油太热的那啥嗯
Alice: The oil is too hot, that's why.
Alice: 因为我们那个面粉里有含水吗
Alice: Because our flour contains water, right?
Tasha:含
Tasha: Yes.
Lucia: 时间太久给他烧开了
Lucia: It took too long, it boiled over.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice: 很棒
Alice: Very nice.
Tasha: 已经与他和平相处了
Tasha: We've made peace with it.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Tasha: 我说已经与他和平相处了
Tasha: I said we've made peace with it.
Alice: 那我帮你把这个洗了吧
Alice: Then I'll help you wash this.
Alice: 给你做收尾工作
Alice: I'll do the finishing touches for you.
Tasha: 好的
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina:  好像幼儿园舞蹈
Katrina: Looks like a kindergarten dance.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 对这个这个音乐比较比较比较可爱
Lucia: Yeah, this music is quite, quite cute.
Tasha: 喂
Tasha: Hello?
Tasha: 啊不用接听
Tasha: Ah, no need to answer.
Lucia: 这 个音乐真的好幼儿园
Lucia: This music really sounds like kindergarten.
Alice: 关火了吗
Alice: Did you turn off the heat?
Tasha:没呢
Tasha: Not yet.
Alice: 翻面了吧该
Alice: It's time to flip it, right?
Tasha: 嗯我看一下
Tasha: Hmm, let me check.
Alice: 熟了吧
Alice: Is it done?
Tasha: 熟了
Tasha: It's done.
Alice:吃吧
Alice: Let's eat.
Lucia: 或者可以把就是难度高一点的动作
Lucia: Or we can just remove the more difficult moves.
Lucia: 给他删掉
Lucia: Yeah, re-choreograph it.
Lucia: 对重新编一下
Lucia: Exactly, rework that part.
Lucia: 我们可以从这段开始
Lucia: We can start from this section.
Lucia: 我觉得这对
Lucia: I think this is right.
Lucia: 然后这个就是前面出现过的那一部分
Lucia: And then this part appeared earlier.
Lucia: 就是可以省略掉一些
Lucia: We can skip some of it.
Lucia: 就是比较强那个什么的
Lucia: It was quite intense...
Tasha: 吃吃吃
Tasha: Eat, eat, eat.
Tasha: 吃
Tasha: Eat.
Tasha: 早饭了
Tasha: It's breakfast time.
Alice: 我拿个充电宝
Alice: I'm getting a power bank.
Alice: 我怕这个没电
Alice: I'm afraid this will run out of battery.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Got it.
Alice: 充电宝在哪里嘞
Alice: Where's the power bank?
Tasha: 人怎么不齐
Tasha: Why isn't everyone here?
Tasha: 要不要喊他一起吃
Tasha: Should we call him to join us for breakfast?
Alice: 他好像刚好像看他出去了还是怎样
Alice: He seemed to have gone out just now.
Tasha: 哦那还要喊他吗
Tasha: Oh, should we still call him?
Lucia: 突然breaking了起来哈哈
Lucia: Suddenly breaking into dance, haha.
Katrina:  对要不就前面1分半看看
Katrina: Yeah, let's check the first one and a half minutes.
Katrina:  1分多够拍
Katrina: One minute is enough to shoot.
Katrina:  哈哈够够呛
Katrina: Haha, barely enough.
Tasha: 谁用碗喝咖啡呢
Tasha: Who drinks coffee from a bowl?
Alice:我
Alice: Me.
Tasha: aha
Tasha: Aha.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha:哎
Tasha: Hey.
Katrina:  到底在哪跳啊
Katrina: Where exactly are we dancing?
Katrina:  外面还是二楼啊
Katrina: Outside or on the second floor?
Lucia: 可能是外面吧
Lucia: Maybe it's outside.
Lucia: 但是其我在想是外面没有什么舞台
Lucia: But then I think there's no stage outside.
Tasha: 哎门怎么打开了
Tasha: Hey, why is the door open?
Katrina:  因为二楼太小了嘛
Katrina: Because the second floor is too small.
Katrina:  那肯定晚上跳舞在外面跳
Katrina: So dancing at night has to be outside.
Katrina:  这10哎刚好就在这
Katrina: And it fits perfectly here.
Lucia:  但我感觉这里这也只能站平着站
Lucia: But I feel like we can only stand flat here.
Alice:好喝
Alice: Tasty.
Tasha: 好喝哈
Tasha: Tasty, huh?
Alice: 好了我结束了
Alice: Okay, I'm done.
Tasha: 啊你结束了
Tasha: Ah, you're done?
Alice: 哈哈对
Alice: Haha, yes.
Lucia: 哦哈哈哈哈可以
Lucia: Oh, hahaha, that's fine.
Lucia: 我们可以想想
Lucia: We can think about it.
Lucia: 上面要什么花纹或者颜色的
Lucia: What kind of patterns or colors we want on top.
Jake: 这什么曲子呀
Jake: What song is this?
Katrina:  奔跑的青春
Katrina: Running Youth.
Katrina:  哈哈但是还没决定好几个
Katrina: Haha, but we haven't decided on a few yet.
Katrina:  要看一下大家难度
Katrina: We need to check the difficulty for everyone.
Katrina:  猪猪侠那个有点慢
Katrina: The Pig Hero one is a bit slow.
Katrina:  拿筷子了吗
Katrina: Did you get the chopsticks?
Tasha: 没呢
Tasha: Not yet.
Jake: 我又被diss了
Jake: I'm being dissed again.
Jake: 你又diss我哈哈
Jake: You're dissing me again, haha.
Jake: 总不回他的消息
Jake: Never replies to his messages.
Jake: 他让我吃早饭
Jake: He tells me to have breakfast.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Amazing.
Tasha: 这还牛哦别看了
Tasha: Is that amazing? Stop looking.
Tasha: 哈哈哈这锅烧导热性太好
Tasha: Hahaha, this pot conducts heat too well.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jake: 哦导多了
Jake: Too much conduction.
Lucia:  我觉得这一看就很好吃
Lucia: I think it looks delicious.
Jake: 是啊
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 不不会
Tasha: No, it won't.
Jake: 为啥不会就会
Jake: Why not? It will.
Lucia:  这个牛奶是你的了
Lucia: This milk is yours.
Tasha: 我没有信心
Tasha: I don't have confidence.
Lucia:  哎呦不好意思
Lucia: Oh, sorry.
Alice: 没事没事
Alice: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake: 试试试试
Jake: Try it, try it.
Lucia:  我如果需要加咖啡请自行加
Lucia: If you need more coffee, please add it yourself.
Lucia:  因为我不知道你要喝多浓
Lucia: Because I don't know how strong you want it.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 好没关系
Jake: It's fine.
Tasha: 加糖
Tasha: Add sugar.
Alice: 给你露西亚你的碗
Alice: Here Lucia, your bowl.
Jake: 糖在哪
Jake: Where's the sugar?
Alice: 我拿一下吧
Alice: Let me get it.
Tasha: 糖糖糖蘸糖
Tasha: Sugar, sugar, dip in sugar.
Lucia:  这个碗
Lucia: This bowl.
Lucia:  少一个再拿一个好了
Lucia: Missing one, let's get another one.
Alice: 我我不要
Alice: No, I don't want it.
Alice: 我的已经结束了
Alice: Mine's already done.
Lucia:  啊啊
Lucia: Ah, ah.
Alice: 我碗都刷完了
Alice: I already washed my bowl.
Lucia:  那我就先拿走一个这个
Lucia: Then I'll take this one away first.
Katrina:  不用加糖
Katrina: No need to add sugar.
Alice: 拿个纸擦一下
Alice: Grab a tissue to wipe it.
Alice: 放放这个放糖吧
Alice: Put it here, put the sugar here.
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake: 要什么纸
Jake: What tissue?
Alice: 这这里面不是放糖蘸的吗
Alice: Isn't this for dipping sugar?
Alice: 还是自己倒自己碗里
Alice: Or just pour it into your own bowl.
Tasha: 这是自己的碗
Tasha: This is your own bowl.
Katrina:  自己碗里吧
Katrina: Just put it in your own bowl.
Alice: 谁的碗
Alice: Whose bowl?
Katrina:  没人用就给他吧
Katrina: If no one's using it, give it to him.
Jake: 好干不干
Jake: Is it dry?
Alice: 你自己倒吧要不
Alice: You pour it yourself then.
Alice: 我不知道你要多少
Alice: I don't know how much you want.
Alice: 你说停吧
Alice: You just say stop.
Jake: 我我我来倒就好
Jake: I'll just pour it myself.
Tasha: 怎么拿了这么多筷子
Tasha: Why did you take so many chopsticks?
Jake: 为什么倒不下来
Jake: Why won't it pour out?
Alice: 因为他有点受潮了
Alice: Because it's a bit damp.
Tasha: 这是绵白糖本来就这么绵
Tasha: This is powdered sugar, it's supposed to be like this.
Jake: 哦好
Jake: Oh, okay.
Jake: 买的好挺好
Jake: Good purchase, very good.
Alice: 哦天哪跟谁
Alice: Oh my god, with whom?
Jake: 我去
Jake: I'm going.
Alice: 分点吧
Alice: Let's share some.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Jake: 强行售卖
Jake: Forcing the sale.
Tasha: 哎哈哈
Tasha: Oh haha
Alice: 你不得你给他弄碎点
Alice: You should break it into smaller pieces for him.
Jake: 强行售卖
Jake: Forcing the sale.
Jake: 可以吧
Jake: Is that okay?
Tasha: 好谢谢
Tasha: Sure, thanks.
Lucia: 这个里面就应该有糖的吗
Lucia: There should be sugar in this, right?
Jake: 还要吗
Jake: Do you want more?
Alice: 蘸糖吗
Alice: Do you dip it in sugar?
Tasha: 不是哈哈
Tasha: No, haha.
Jake: 分点
Jake: Share some.
Alice: 江苏人的
Alice: Jiangsu style.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Jake: 分分你一点
Jake: Share a bit with you.
Lucia:  呃也可以
Lucia: Uh, okay.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 你这个倒太多了
Lucia: You poured too much.
Tasha: 对他倒太多了哈哈
Tasha: Yeah, he poured too much, haha.
Katrina:  啊yes okay
Katrina: Ah yes, okay.
Jake: 对都都都是
Jake: Right, it's all...
Jake: 是我放太多了
Jake: I put too much.
Alice: 你要糖吗雨轩
Alice: Do you want some sugar, Yuxuan?
Tasha: 然后嗯贴面蘸
Tasha: And then, uh, dip it.
Jake: 要吗好
Jake: Do you want it? Okay.
Katrina:  我不要糖
Katrina: I don't want sugar.
Jake: 你也不要
Jake: You don't want it either.
Alice: 我不吃糖
Alice: I don't eat sugar.
Alice: 我会流鼻血
Alice: It gives me nosebleeds.
Jake: 啊确实
Jake: Ah, true.
Katrina:  这舞也行
Katrina: This dance is okay.
Tasha: 你要接受
Tasha: You have to accept it.
Lucia: 这个好像是我们那校庆
Lucia: This seems like our school anniversary celebration.
Katrina:  我高中跳过
Katrina: I danced it in high school.
Katrina:  高中晚会跳过
Katrina: Danced it at the high school party.
Lucia:  虽然我觉得动作可能不完全一样
Lucia: Although I think the moves might be different.
Lucia:  但就这个背景音乐
Lucia: But the background music is the same.
Katrina:  this其实还行
Katrina: This actually is okay.
Katrina:  如果你能接受奔跑的青春的话
Katrina: If you can accept the youth of running,
Katrina:  那你更加能接受这个
Katrina: Then you can totally accept this.
Katrina:  慢一点动作更简单
Katrina: Slower movements are even simpler.
Katrina:  噜噜响
Katrina: Rumbling sounds.
Lucia: 就这个也可以
Lucia: This one works too.
Lucia:  这个鼓点也比较清晰
Lucia: The beat is quite clear.
Lucia: 就我喜欢这种
Lucia: I like this kind.
Lucia: 我能很快找到他的节奏的
Lucia: I can quickly find its rhythm.
Alice: 充电宝在哪
Alice: Where's the power bank?
Alice: 我这个可能快快要充电了
Alice: Mine might need charging soon.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 别把我的充电宝拔走了
Tasha: Don't take my power bank away.
Alice: 你告诉我在哪我去拿就行了
Alice: Just tell me where it is, I'll get it myself.
Jake: 我我来拿我来拿
Jake: I'll get it, I'll get it.
Alice: 味道怎么样
Alice: How's the taste?
Lucia: 很棒
Lucia: It's great.
Lucia: 特别好
Lucia: Really good.
Tasha: 我觉得用错面团了啊面粉了
Tasha: I think we used the wrong dough or flour.
Jake: 密度刚好
Jake: The density is just right.
Jake: 这这个面的密度刚好
Jake: The density of this dough is just right.
Jake: 这是你的吗
Jake: Is this yours?
Jake: 这是这是这是
Jake: This, this, this is...
Jake: 这是啥呀
Jake: What is this?
Alice: 这个不知道谁的
Alice: I don't know whose it is.
Alice: 这不是他的
Alice: It's not his.
Alice: 他的是个小蝴蝶
Alice: His has a little butterfly on it.
Jake: 这啥啊
Jake: What is this?
Alice: 不对小翅膀
Alice: No, it's little wings.
Jake: 怎么看呢
Jake: How do we know?
Alice: 不知道这是谁的
Alice: Don't know whose it is.
Lucia: 莫非是我的吗
Lucia: Could it be mine?
Jake: 是露西亚
Jake: It's Lucia's.
Alice: 啊姜
Alice: Oh, ginger.
Jake: 这这是姜
Jake: This is ginger.
Jake: 哦是吗
Jake: Oh, really?
Lucia: 嗯是
Lucia: Yes, it is.
Jake: 这是姜
Jake: This is ginger.
Jake: 哦哦哦哦哦哦好好
Jake: Oh oh oh, okay, okay.
Jake: 那你要点
Jake: Do you want some?
Jake: 你也要点
Jake: Do you want some too?
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Jake: 就先放这些
Jake: Let's put these here first.
Katrina:  我觉得跳那个
Katrina: I think jumping to that one...
Katrina:  不如跳这个
Katrina: How about this one instead?
Alice: 味道还行吗
Alice: Does it taste okay?
Tasha: 啊哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Katrina:  这还能3分钟呢
Katrina: This can still go for 3 more minutes.
Katrina:  这这动作都重复了
Katrina: The actions are repeating now.
Jake: 行这个比较明显
Jake: Alright, this is pretty obvious.
Alice: 啊yes yes
Alice: Ah yes yes.
Jake: 正好你坐着
Jake: Perfect, you're sitting down.
Katrina:  哦我要充电是吗
Katrina: Oh, do I need to charge?
Jake: 可以冲一会
Jake: You can charge for a bit.
Jake: 哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake: 是不不够啊
Jake: Is it not enough?
Katrina:  有一种机器人被连上电的感觉
Katrina: It feels like a robot being plugged in.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 连上之后记忆加速
Jake: Once plugged in, memory accelerates.
Jake: 1秒学舞
Jake: Learn to dance in one second.
Katrina:  激活激活了正好
Katrina: Activation complete.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 这是谁的
Jake: Whose is this?
Tasha: 这个特别好吃
Tasha: This is really tasty.
Jake: 哈哈哈我
Jake: Hahaha, mine?
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha.
Jake: 我的是吧嗯
Jake: It's mine, right? Hmm.
Jake: 真的吗
Jake: Really?
Tasha: 真的这是第
Tasha: Really, this is the first...
Tasha: 一个成果
Tasha: Result.
Jake: 真的哦真吃了
Jake: Really? You really ate it.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 假吃了还能
Lucia: Even fake eating is still...
Tasha: 别吃了吧哈哈
Tasha: Don't eat it anymore, haha.
Jake: 刚刚那个猪猪侠是怎么跳的
Jake: How did the Piggy Hero jump just now?
Jake: 我很好奇
Jake: I'm really curious.
Katrina:  猪猪侠特别简单
Katrina: Piggy Hero is super simple.
Katrina:  就1234才做一个动作
Katrina: Just 1, 2, 3, 4 and you do one move.
Lucia: 对这个比较简单哦
Lucia: Yeah, this one's pretty easy.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 好好哎这个看一下
Jake: Okay, okay, let's take a look at this.
Lucia: 她的节奏节奏感没有那么
Lucia: Her rhythm, her sense of rhythm isn't that...
Lucia: 那么明确
Lucia: ...clear.
Jake: 嗯确实有点呆
Jake: Hmm, she's indeed a bit stiff.
Lucia: 那我们可以像雨轩说的
Lucia: Then we can, like Yuxuan said,
Lucia: 考虑比较可爱的造型
Lucia: consider a cuter style.
Lucia: 然后跳这个
Lucia: And then dance to this.
Jake: 可以都可以
Jake: Sure, that's possible.
Katrina:  人人都可以
Katrina: Everyone can do it.
Katrina:  一人带个蘑菇头
Katrina: Each person wears a mushroom head.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 啊哈哈
Lucia: Ahaha.
Lucia: 很有道理
Lucia: Makes sense.
Katrina:  嗯买两个头套就行
Katrina: Hmm, just buy two head covers.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Sure.
Jake: 买个那那种气球
Jake: Buy those kinds of balloons.
Jake: 风吹起来
Jake: Blow them up.
Katrina:  造型的气球吗
Katrina: Shaped balloons?
Katrina:  哦哦哦那个风吹那个人那个的
Katrina: Oh oh oh, the kind that gets blown by the wind.
Lucia: 嗯是外卖到了吗
Lucia: Hmm, is the delivery here?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 不是外卖美团买药
Lucia: Not delivery, Meituan for medicine.
Tasha: 点外卖了哦
Tasha: Ordered delivery.
Jake: 来了
Jake: It's here.
Jake: 嗯嗯好
Jake: Yeah, yeah, okay.
Tasha: 嗯我以为午饭到了
Tasha: Hmm, I thought lunch was here.
Lucia: 喂你好
Lucia: Hello, hi.
Jake: 嗯嗯哼哼哼
Jake: Mm-hmm, uh-huh.
Lucia:  呃我们是黄色铁门吗
Lucia: Uh, are we the yellow iron gate?
Katrina:  现在在这
Katrina: He's here now.
Katrina:  我听到他声音了
Katrina: I can hear him.
Katrina:  他就在这
Katrina: He's right here.
Lucia: 哦这样子
Lucia: Oh, I see.
Lucia: 呃应该是同一个
Lucia: Uh, it should be the same one.
Lucia: 您稍等一下
Lucia: Please wait a moment.
Katrina:  是蓝绿色的
Katrina: It's blue-green.
Lucia: 是一个蓝绿色的建筑
Lucia: It's a blue-green building.
Alice: 薇薇这个饼你还满意吗
Alice: Tasha, are you satisfied with this pancake?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Tasha: 嗯煎的有点
Tasha: Hmm, it's a bit overcooked.
Alice: 还不错吧
Alice: But it's not bad, right?
Tasha: 你吃了吗
Tasha: Have you tried it?
Alice: 没有啊
Alice: No, I haven't.
Tasha: 你还挺好的
Tasha: You're doing pretty well.
Alice: 那就行很棒
Alice: That's fine, it's great.
Tasha: 可见其实什么面粉并不重要
Tasha: Actually, it shows that the type of flour isn't that important.
Tasha: 那个锅的问题
Tasha: It's the pan's issue.
Alice: 过筛也可没没关系
Alice: Sifting it or not doesn't matter.
Tasha: 那个锅的问题
Tasha: It's the pan's issue.
Jake: 你耳朵怎么这么好
Jake: How is your hearing so good?
Jake: 还是隔音太差了
Jake: Or is the soundproofing too bad?
Katrina:  哈哈哈我刚以为你房间有人说话
Katrina: Hahaha, I thought someone was talking in your room.
Jake: 哦是这样
Jake: Oh, I see.
Jake: 怎么去郑州
Jake: How do you get to Zhengzhou?
Tasha: 哎你怎么是吧
Tasha: Hey, why are you...
Jake: 你刚刚打电话说的
Jake: You just mentioned it on the phone.
Jake: 去干嘛呀
Jake: What are you going to do there?
Alice: 跟我约会
Alice: Going on a date with me.
Jake: 哦可以
Jake: Oh, okay.
Katrina:  你要去郑州吗
Katrina: Are you going to Zhengzhou?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
Katrina:  你去郑州干啥开会吗
Katrina: What are you going to do in Zhengzhou, attending a meeting?
Tasha: 去玩五一
Tasha: Going there for the May Day holiday.
Jake: 五一去郑州
Jake: Going to Zhengzhou for May Day?
Jake: 可以人会很多吧
Jake: There will be a lot of people, right?
Alice: 啊你去郑州
Alice: Ah, you're going to Zhengzhou?
Alice: 不是你郑州去哪啊
Alice: Where in Zhengzhou are you going?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Katrina:  哈哈哈我有个舍友也是郑州
Katrina: Hahaha, I have a roommate from Zhengzhou.
Alice: 你去
Alice: You're going...
Lucia: 本地人
Lucia: A local.
Alice: 你问我吧问我吧
Alice: You can ask me, ask me.
Tasha: 哦问我吧
Tasha: Oh, ask me.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Uh.
Tasha: 我不知道去哪呢还
Tasha: I don't know where to go yet.
Tasha: 他们安排我
Tasha: They'll arrange it for me.
Tasha: 我可是个P人
Tasha: I'm just a nobody.
Alice: 我的天啊
Alice: Oh my god.
Tasha: 我我跟着走
Tasha: I'll just follow along.
Alice: 我觉得去哪玩我都理解不了
Alice: I feel like I don't get the point of going anywhere to play.
Lucia: 哈哈哈嘉怡
Lucia: Hahaha Jiayi
Lucia: 我只有碰到比我更屁的朋友的时候
Lucia: Only when I meet friends who are even lazier than me
Alice: 带你去洛阳
Alice: I'll take you to Luoyang.
Lucia: 我才会做计划
Lucia: Do I make plans.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Alice: 哈哈哈你去洛阳跟开封都挺近的
Alice: Haha, you know Luoyang and Kaifeng are quite close.
Alice: 从郑州东站出发哈哈哈
Alice: Starting from Zhengzhou East Station, haha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈什么
Tasha: Hahaha, what?
Katrina:  哈哈哈郑州最好玩的就是郑州东站
Katrina: Hahaha, the best part of Zhengzhou is Zhengzhou East Station.
Tasha: 我不是去
Tasha: I'm not going.
Alice: 郑州东站哈哈
Alice: Zhengzhou East Station, haha.
Katrina:  买一张票去别的地方
Katrina: Buy a ticket to go somewhere else.
Tasha: 啊好
Tasha: Ah, okay.
Alice: 我跟你说一下
Alice: Let me tell you something.
Alice: 超级好吃的那种甜水铺你可以去
Alice: There's this super delicious dessert shop you can go to.
Tasha: 啊你说吧
Tasha: Oh, go ahead.
Tasha: 我让万一我不去他们能吃
Tasha: In case I don't go, they can still eat there.
Alice: 我觉得那一栋楼只有
Alice: I think in that building, there are only
Alice: 就是为数不多的几家活着
Alice: a few places still surviving.
Tasha: 你说
Tasha: Go on.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Mm-hmm.
Jake: 这个咖啡我是怎么搞啊
Jake: How do I make this coffee?
Alice: 直接啊浓缩液倒进去往上拔
Alice: Just pour the concentrate in and pull it up.
Katrina:  就一条拔出来
Katrina: Just pull one out.
Jake: 哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, got it.
Alice: 就是大上海城
Alice: It's like Shanghai City.
Jake: 有点多哎
Jake: That's a lot.
Tasha: 大上海城然后呢
Tasha: Shanghai City, and then?
Katrina:  倒进来就这么
Katrina: Just pour it in like this.
Alice: 东东鲜芋圆
Alice: Dong Dong Fresh Taro Balls.
Katrina:  它非常浓郁
Katrina: It's very rich.
Alice: 东西南北的东
Alice: Dong from East.
Tasha: 东东鲜芋圆好了
Tasha: Dong Dong Fresh Taro Balls, got it.
Alice: 嗯东东鲜芋圆就他们家巨好吃
Alice: Yeah, Dong Dong Fresh Taro Balls, their stuff is super tasty.
Alice: 你会发现
Alice: You'll find that
Alice: 那个商城基本上是倒闭的状态
Alice: the shopping mall is basically in a state of collapse.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice: 哎
Alice: Oh.
Alice: 你五一要真的去的话你可以来我家玩
Alice: If you really go during May Day, you can come to my house.
Alice: 真的你要不住我家吧
Alice: Seriously, you can stay at my place.
Katrina:  节省了一笔房费
Katrina: That saves a lot on accommodation costs.
Alice: 真的你要不住我家吧
Alice: Seriously, you can stay at my place.
Alice: 我家也没啥人
Alice: There aren't many people at my house.
Jake: 你你还能带几个人
Jake: How many people can you bring?
Jake: 哈哈哈住几个人
Jake: Haha, how many people can stay?
Tasha: 能住几个哈哈
Tasha: How many can stay, haha.
Alice: 啊哈啊你有几对
Alice: Haha, how many do you have?
Lucia: 对我这离你家很近
Lucia: Right, my place is close to yours.
Lucia: 我也可以住两个人吧
Lucia: I can also host two people.
Tasha: 我天呐哈哈
Tasha: Oh my, haha.
Alice: 你你们有几个人
Alice: How many people do you have?
Lucia: 一只手
Lucia: One hand.
Tasha: 应该是3个到4个
Tasha: It should be 3 to 4 people.
Tasha: 呃 4个到5个吧
Tasha: Uh, maybe 4 to 5 people.
Alice: 啊把我第
Alice: Ah, I'll...
Alice: 赶出家门
Alice: ...kick someone out.
Tasha: 啊哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈嗯
Tasha: Ah, hahaha, hahaha, hahaha, haha.
Alice: 让他让他不许回来
Alice: Tell them they're not allowed to come back.
Alice: 然后就可以腾出来房间住了
Alice: Then we can free up some rooms.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha:4 月18号8点开始抢票
Tasha: On April 18th at 8 AM, tickets go on sale.
Tasha: 怎么什么都要抢好烦啊
Tasha: Why does everything need to be snatched, it's so annoying.
Jake: 五一要抢票是吧
Jake: You need to grab tickets for May Day, right?
Jake: 完了五一那会儿我回新加坡
Jake: I'm going back to Singapore during May Day.
Jake: 是不是特别贵
Jake: Is it really expensive?
Jake: 呵呵呵我没订票
Jake: Haha, I haven't booked my ticket yet.
Katrina:  还没订票
Katrina: Haven't booked yet?
Jake:P人不会订票
Jake: I don't know how to book tickets.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 你可以讲你之前的那个故事
Lucia: You can tell your previous story.
Alice: 我五一要回家了
Alice: I'm going home for May Day.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice: 我现在还没开始定
Alice: I haven't started booking yet.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈连我一个P人都觉得震惊
Lucia: Haha, even I, a newbie, am shocked.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Jake: 呵呵我上了飞
Jake: Haha, I'm on the plane.
Jake: 先去飞机场再买票
Jake: First go to the airport and then buy the ticket.
Katrina:  嗯我是受不了
Katrina: Hmm, I can't stand it.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice: 啊什么
Alice: What?
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake: 因为
Jake: Because...
Tasha: 先去飞机场再买票
Tasha: First go to the airport and then buy the ticket.
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake: 因为这比较省钱
Jake: Because it's cheaper.
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 因为如果我提前买票通常赶不上飞机
Jake: Because if I buy the ticket in advance, I usually miss the flight.
Jake: 所以就要改签
Jake: So I have to reschedule.
Alice: 原来是这样
Alice: Oh, I see.
Alice: 我的天呐
Alice: Oh my god.
Katrina:  但是你到那买不是很贵吗
Katrina: But isn't it more expensive if you buy it there?
Katrina:  有的时候
Katrina: Sometimes.
Jake: 但是我每次都赶不上飞机
Jake: But I always miss the flight.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice: 是原来是这样
Alice: Oh, I see.
Katrina:  受不了你了真的
Katrina: I can't stand you, really.
Jake: 对所以比较省钱
Jake: Yeah, so it's cheaper.
Alice: 这是能说的吗
Alice: Can you say that?
Jake: 不是能说了吗
Jake: Can’t I say that?
Alice: 给外国人一点震撼哈
Alice: Shocking for foreigners, huh?
Katrina:  嘿嘿嘿
Katrina: Hehehe.
Alice:笑死
Alice: Laughing to death.
Jake: 这个可以说吧
Jake: I think it's okay to say.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Tasha: OK
Tasha: OK.
Jake: 以前试了很多次教训
Jake: I’ve tried many times before.
Jake: 就是每次都可能提前40分钟check in
Jake: Every time, I might need to check in 40 minutes early.
Jake: 然后我可能就3938分钟到
Jake: Then I arrive at 39 or 38 minutes.
Jake: 然后呵呵呵
Jake: And then, haha...
Jake: 就很失望
Jake: It's really disappointing.
Jake: 以后就不买票了
Jake: So I don't buy tickets in advance anymore.
Alice: 呵我第一次听说
Alice: Haha, it's the first time I've heard that.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia: 是不是很让人震惊
Lucia: Isn’t it shocking?
Alice: 我觉得我已经很很那啥了
Alice: I thought I was already quite something.
Jake: 哎路亚你这个关了
Jake: Hey Lucia, you turned it off.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Huh?
Jake: 是哎为什么会关
Jake: Yeah, why did it turn off?
Alice: 嗯充电
Alice: Hmm, charging.
Lucia: 哎有充着电
Lucia: Hey, it’s charging.
Jake: 看一下看一下
Jake: Check it, check it.
Jake: 什么什么
Jake: What, what?
Tasha: 说不出话来
Tasha: Can't say anything.
Tasha: 还是钱太多了还是还是钱太多了
Tasha: Is it too much money, is it still too much money?
Jake: 哈哈哈太多了
Jake: Hahaha, too much.
Alice: 震惊了
Alice: Shocked.
Lucia: 他被你吓着了
Lucia: He got scared by you.
Jake: 不是没有
Jake: No, it's not.
Jake: 还是要省钱
Jake: We still need to save money.
Tasha: 还是钱太多了家里
Tasha: Still too much money at home.
Jake: 还是不能白花钱
Jake: But we can't waste money.
Jake: 就是可以贵一点
Jake: It can be a bit expensive.
Jake: 但是不能白花钱
Jake: But we can't waste money.
Tasha: 还是家里钱太多了
Tasha: Still too much money at home.
Katrina:  笑死我了
Katrina: You’re killing me with laughter.
Lucia: 他又变白了
Lucia: He turned pale again.
Lucia: 但是我没有关
Lucia: But I didn't turn it off.
Lucia:  我的嗯嗯哦
Lucia: Mine, mm-hmm, oh.
Tasha: 啊哈哈
Tasha: Ah haha.
Lucia:  关闭了吗
Lucia: Did it shut off?
Tasha: 接完接电话是不是会自动关
Tasha: Does it shut off automatically after a call?
Lucia: 应该会影响吧
Lucia: It should affect it, right?
Jake: 应该不会
Jake: It shouldn't.
Lucia:  哎他好像真的刚才那圈突然掉线了
Lucia: Hey, it really disconnected just now.
Lucia: 那我再来一个
Lucia: Let me try another one.
Alice: 喂喂你们那个规划我真的很好奇
Alice: Hey, hey, I'm really curious about your plan.
Alice: 我也想知道郑州有啥玩的
Alice: I also want to know what to do in Zhengzhou.
Tasha: 不知道呀玩啥呀
Tasha: Don't know, what to do?
Katrina:  看下外地人做的攻略你就知道
Katrina: Look at guides made by outsiders, and you'll know.
Alice: 对对对哈哈哈
Alice: Right, right, haha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake: 哎
Jake: Hey.
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: Don't know.
Tasha: 我什么都不知道
Tasha: I know nothing.
Tasha: 就今天打电话说去郑州玩嘛
Tasha: Just got a call today about going to Zhengzhou for fun.
Tasha: 哈哈我说有空我就去
Tasha: Haha, I said I'll go if I have time.
Alice: 是不是你们要去演唱会之类的
Alice: Are you guys going to a concert or something?
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Really?
Alice: 是吗我不知道啊
Alice: Really? I didn't know that.
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I didn't know either.
Katrina:  你怎么不来武汉玩
Katrina: Why don't you come to Wuhan to hang out?
Tasha: 武汉
Tasha: Wuhan?
Tasha: 没有人邀请我去哈哈哈啊
Tasha: No one invited me, haha.
Katrina:  觉得武汉还是我邀请你
Katrina: Do you think Wuhan is better? I'll invite you.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha
Katrina:  武汉比郑州好玩一点点
Katrina: Wuhan is a bit more fun than Zhengzhou.
Lucia: 我还没去过郑州
Lucia: I've never been to Zhengzhou.
Tasha: 我也没有去过
Tasha: Me neither.
Katrina:  武汉但是武汉五一人应该很多
Katrina: But Wuhan will be crowded during May Day.
Alice: 来吧来找我吧
Alice: Come on, come visit me.
Alice: 我五一应该在家
Alice: I'll be home during May Day.
Tasha: 哈哈真的
Tasha: Haha, really?
Alice: 我也没开始订票
Alice: I haven't started booking tickets yet.
Alice: 我一看那个票售罄了
Alice: When I checked, they were sold out.
Alice: 然后我还没开始订
Alice: So I haven't started booking.
Lucia:  行那果然是全员P人
Lucia: Well, looks like everyone's last minute.
Alice: 无所谓反正
Alice: Doesn't matter anyway.
Alice: 嗯买不到票就只能
Alice: If I can't get a ticket, then I just can't.
Lucia: 我也经常会提前两三天才订
Lucia: I also often book two or three days in advance.
Lucia: 但是嗯您知道吗哈哈哈
Lucia: But, you know, haha.
Jake: 一般大概也就提前两个小时对
Jake: Usually, it's about two hours in advance, right.
Jake: 就提前两个小时就能有飞机
Jake: You can get a flight two hours in advance.
Alice: 第一次听说
Alice: First time hearing that.
Alice: 真的闻所未闻
Alice: Really, never heard of it.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake: 到了机场一看那个板我觉得这个不错
Jake: When you get to the airport and see the board, I think it's pretty good.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake: 看看多少钱
Jake: Check the price.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈闻所未闻
Alice: Hahahaha, never heard of it.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 大开眼界
Lucia: Eye-opening.
Katrina:  哈
Katrina: Ha.
Alice: 我觉得
Alice: I think
Alice: 我提前一两天买票已经挺极限了
Alice: Booking one or two days in advance is already pushing it.
Alice: 就是别人可能他一放票
Alice: It's just that when others release tickets...
Alice: 或者说是提前几天就是放票的
Alice: Or maybe the tickets were released a few days in advance.
Alice: 提前几天
Alice: A few days in advance.
Alice: 可能就一共推往前推个一二十天
Alice: Maybe they were released about ten to twenty days earlier.
Alice: 就开始抢了
Alice: And then people start snatching them.
Alice: 然后我大学的时候也是
Alice: Back when I was in college,
Alice: 他们都已经开始想
Alice: They would already be planning
Alice: 哪天抢哪天的票了
Alice: Which day to grab tickets.
Alice: 然后每次都是快回家了
Alice: And every time, just before going home,
Alice: 我想要不看看票吧
Alice: I'd think, why not check the tickets?
Alice: 一看啦啦啦售罄哈哈哈
Alice: And then, surprise, surprise, sold out, hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈是
Jake: Haha, yes.
Alice: 好吧
Alice: Alright.
Jake: 是有一次我回家飞南京然后
Jake: There was one time I flew back home to Nanjing and
Jake: 就没赶上嘛
Jake: I missed it.
Jake: 自然而然没有赶上
Jake: Naturally, I didn't make it.
Jake: 呃那一天最后
Jake: Uh, that day, in the end,
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha:自然而然没赶上
Tasha: Naturally, didn't make it.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Jake: 对自然而然没有赶上
Jake: Yeah, naturally didn't make it.
Jake: 所以所以那天看的最后一班
Jake: So, so that day I caught the last flight
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 回中国了
Jake: Back to China.
Jake: 先到了成都
Jake: First arrived in Chengdu.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake: 对到了成都待了一晚上
Jake: Yeah, stayed in Chengdu for a night.
Jake: 我觉得成都到南京应该高铁也挺快
Jake: I thought the high-speed train from Chengdu to Nanjing would be fast.
Tasha: 然后也没赶上
Tasha: And I missed it too.
Katrina:  很很远很远
Katrina: Very, very far.
Katrina:  1,800公里
Katrina: 1,800 kilometers.
Jake: 对我我我以为挺快的
Jake: Yeah, I thought it would be fast.
Jake: 因为我想北京也挺
Jake: Because I thought Beijing was also quite
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake: 就差不多距离吧
Jake: About the same distance, right?
Jake: 对吧大概有几个小时
Jake: Yeah, it should take just a few hours.
Tasha: 啊然后赶上好吗
Tasha: Ah, and did you make it?
Jake: 结果要那个是飞机场买的所以
Jake: Turns out, I had to buy it at the airport, so
Jake: 赶上哈哈哈哈
Jake: I made it, hahahaha.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha.
Jake: 就是去到成都之对那
Jake: So when we got to Chengdu, right?
Jake: 那个是买到了成都之后
Jake: After arriving in Chengdu,
Jake: 一晚上就在这个春熙路晃悠了一晚上
Jake: We spent the whole night wandering around Chunxi Road.
Jake: 然后因为第二天早上的飞机
Jake: Because we had a flight the next morning,
Jake: 然后就飞走了
Jake: We just flew out.
Jake: 原来想坐高铁的
Jake: Initially, we wanted to take the high-speed train,
Jake: 结果
Jake: But,
Jake: 那个高铁大概也得七八个小时是吧
Jake: That high-speed train would take about seven to eight hours, right?
Katrina:  没有高铁
Katrina: There's no high-speed train.
Katrina:  成都到武汉都要9个小时
Katrina: Chengdu to Wuhan takes nine hours.
Katrina:  武汉到南京还要2 3个小时
Katrina: And Wuhan to Nanjing takes another 2-3 hours.
Alice: 它那个线路不一定
Alice: The route isn't fixed.
Katrina:  但是但是10小时以上
Katrina: But it's over 10 hours.
Jake: 太可怕了
Jake: That's terrifying.
Katrina:  我一般都是买的飞机票
Katrina: I usually buy plane tickets.
Katrina:  我当时也以为
Katrina: I thought,
Katrina:  我以为那个武汉长沙
Katrina: I thought Wuhan, Changsha,
Katrina:  成都是挨在一起的
Katrina: And Chengdu were close to each other.
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina:  武汉跟长沙只有一个小时
Katrina: Wuhan and Changsha are only an hour apart.
Katrina:  但是到到川渝那就很远
Katrina: But getting to Sichuan and Chongqing is far.
Katrina:  就要6个小时
Katrina: It takes six hours.
Jake: 要绕一圈
Jake: You have to take a detour.
Jake: 我也觉得应该挺近
Jake: I thought it was closer.
Jake: 我也觉得这个中国高铁应该没这么
Jake: I thought the high-speed trains in China wouldn't be so...
Jake: 哈哈哈没这么慢
Jake: Hahaha, so slow.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Jake: 我高铁有十几个小时
Jake: I've taken high-speed trains for over ten hours.
Lucia: 虽然成都到武汉比成都到北京还慢
Lucia: Although Chengdu to Wuhan is slower than Chengdu to Beijing.
Lucia:  嗯总感觉好像
Lucia: Hmm, it always feels like,
Lucia: 感觉上应该就是他到北京更远一些
Lucia: It feels like Beijing is farther.
Alice: 现高铁是不是降过速了
Alice: Has the high-speed train slowed down?
Alice: 现在高铁是不是降过速了
Alice: Has the high-speed train slowed down now?
Alice: 现在一般都300多了
Alice: Now it's generally over 300 km/h.
Jake: 对都是300对
Jake: Yes, it's all over 300.
Alice: 嗯都是300多
Alice: Hmm, all over 300.
Jake: 300整怎么
Jake: Exactly 300, how...
Tasha: 太离谱了
Tasha: That's ridiculous.
Tasha: 他帮我找出来了北京到郑州的公交票
Tasha: He helped me find a bus ticket from Beijing to Zhengzhou.
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Alice: 什么
Alice: What?
Jake: 倒多少趟
Jake: How many times?
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Alice: 告诉我哈哈
Alice: Tell me, haha
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Tasha: 我说我说如果我不去
Tasha: I said, I said, if I don't go
Jake: 哎狭路共赏
Jake: Hey, it's a narrow escape
Tasha: 我说我说如果我24号去北京
Tasha: I said, I said, if I go to Beijing on the 24th
Tasha: 我他说不去打死我
Tasha: He said he'd kill me if I didn't go
Alice: 不去打死
Alice: Kill you if you don't go?
Tasha: 我说住哪
Tasha: I said, where to stay
Tasha: 然后他说麻麻利利的把公交票订下来
Tasha: Then he said to quickly book the bus ticket
Tasha: 哈哈啊
Tasha: Haha
Lucia: 哈哈哈你朋友是真人吗
Lucia: Hahaha, is your friend for real?
Alice: 啊我的天
Alice: Oh my god
Jake: 北京任意点
Jake: Any place in Beijing
Katrina:  不是怎么坐公交来这啊
Katrina: How do you take the bus here?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Jake: 啥意思
Jake: What does that mean?
Tasha: 北京任意点到郑州
Tasha: Any place in Beijing to Zhengzhou
Lucia: 是可以坐公交去郑州
Lucia: You can take a bus to Zhengzhou?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Alice: 我的天呐
Alice: Oh my god
Tasha: 上门接送
Tasha: Door-to-door service
Lucia: 上门接送
Lucia: Door-to-door service
Jake: 哈哈上
Jake: Haha, really?
Alice: 我的天呐哈哈哈
Alice: Oh my god, hahaha
Katrina:  这是什么新的服务
Katrina: What kind of new service is this?
Jake: 专车是吧
Jake: Is it a special car?
Jake: 专车才280
Jake: Only 280?
Lucia: 对我也想问
Lucia: Yes, I wanted to ask too
Lucia:  这么便宜啊
Lucia: It's so cheap
Alice: 比我高铁还便宜
Alice: Cheaper than my high-speed train ticket
Alice: 但是时间太长了屁股要坐烂了
Alice: But it takes too long, my butt would go numb
Tasha: 10个小时
Tasha: 10 hours
Tasha: 唉那好吧
Tasha: Well, okay then
Tasha: 9.5个小时
Tasha: 9.5 hours
Lucia:  咱在国内也没必要
Lucia: We don't need to within the country
Lucia: 做什么fuss或者哈哈哈
Lucia: 会所BUS这种东西
Tasha: 到那再说开宾馆
Alice: 我看看
Alice: 绝了
Alice: 不是他是怎么能想到这条路的
Katrina:  儿子我能想到这条路
Alice: 我真是闻所未闻
Tasha: 他一会让我骑自行车过去哈哈哈
Alice: 你骑个小黄
Jake: 北京到郑州自行车骑多久
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: 不知道
Lucia:  到地了饭都
Jake: 就是五一
Lucia: 接收站都不接收他
Alice: 调度费太贵了哈哈
Jake: 是
Tasha: 那我要用那种第一次的手机号去注册
Tasha: 然后他说新人首次可以免费调度
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈你可以每路上每到一个城市
Lucia: Hahaha, you could, at every city you pass,
Lucia: 换一两个小黄
Lucia: switch out one or two Nicous.
Lucia: 就挨着的城市之间
Lucia: Just between the neighboring cities.
Tasha: 不是你在思考这件事的可行性吗
Tasha: Aren't you considering the feasibility of this?
Tasha: 我到那要不要先治腿
Tasha: Should I treat my leg first when I get there?
Alice: 天哪
Alice: Oh my god.
Alice: 为了盘醋包了盘饺子
Alice: Made dumplings to go with the vinegar.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Alice: 太好笑了
Alice: That's so funny.
Lucia: 为了保证你能顺利去郑州啊嗯
Lucia: To ensure you can safely get to Zhengzhou, hmm.
Alice: 闻所未闻
Alice: Never heard of that before.
Jake: 导航郑州哪个医院好
Jake: Navigate to find the best hospital in Zhengzhou.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahahaha
Jake: 骨科
Jake: Orthopedics.
Tasha: 我懂了就这样子
Tasha: Got it, just like that.
Tasha: 我在中途然后摔倒了
Tasha: I fell halfway,
Tasha: 然后郑州开救护车过来接我哈哈哈
Tasha: and then Zhengzhou sent an ambulance to pick me up, hahaha.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Alice: 哎压住了谁手机
Alice: Hey, whose phone got pressed down?
Alice: 郑州确实有
Alice: Zhengzhou does have
Alice: 骨科医院
Alice: an orthopedic hospital
Alice: 离东站不是很远
Alice: It's not far from the east station
Alice: 可以到了直接去哈哈
Alice: You can go directly there, haha
Lucia: 也不用去宾馆了是吧哈哈哈
Lucia: No need to go to the hotel, right? Hahaha
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Tasha: 五一
Tasha: Labor Day
Jake: 五一
Jake: Labor Day
Jake: 五一放几天
Jake: How many days off?
Alice: 没看
Alice: Didn't check
Jake: 7天吧
Jake: Probably 7 days
Lucia: 少说5天嗯
Lucia: At least 5 days, yeah
Alice: 休不够就请假
Alice: If it's not enough, take leave
Lucia: 你你还可以大胆一点
Lucia: You can be bolder
Tasha: 你你
Tasha: You, you
Lucia: 休不够就翘课
Lucia: If it's not enough, skip class
Tasha: 对啊我今天就翘课了
Tasha: Yeah, I skipped class today
Jake: 什么课啊
Jake: What class?
Tasha: 什么课不重要
Tasha: It's not important
Tasha: 我其实没见过他呢哈哈
Tasha: I actually haven't met him, haha
Alice:你要跳舞吗
Alice: Are you going to dance?
Jake: 好多人啊哈哈哈
Jake: So many people, haha
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Alice: 好多人啊
Alice: So many people
Alice: 我看最近有什么演唱会的票今天晚上可以开始抢了
Alice: I saw there are concert tickets available tonight
Katrina:  这舞还行这版本
Katrina: This dance is okay, this version
Katrina:  一分五十 六
Katrina: One minute fifty-six
Tasha: 在北京的医院居然要抢
Tasha: In Beijing hospitals, you have to grab
Tasha: 抢票你知道吗
Tasha: Grab tickets, you know?
Tasha: 是要提前7天的时候就要开始抢
Tasha: You have to start grabbing them 7 days in advance
Lucia: 哎我明明充电它为什么又变成低电量
Lucia: I clearly charged it, why is it low battery again?
Tasha: 那个医治的号
Tasha: The treatment number
Tasha: 挂号费咋这么贵 100块钱
Tasha: The registration fee is so expensive, 100 yuan
Alice: 你挂的是什么号啊
Alice: What kind of registration?
Katrina:  怎么又有SOLO啊
Katrina: Why is there a solo again?
Tasha: 专家号
Tasha: Specialist number
Alice: 那专家号是会贵一点
Alice: Specialist numbers are more expensive
Jake: 呃没关系
Jake: Uh, it's okay.
Alice: 你会发现专家号也就给你诊疗个
Alice: You'll find that even the specialist appointment only gives you a consultation.
Lucia: 可是我刚办上的时候他还30%
Lucia: But when I first got it, it was still 30%.
Lucia: 但是中间有那么一小一小段时间没插
Lucia: But there was a small period of time in between without it.
Alice:一 点点时间
Alice: Just a little bit of time.
Tasha: 还有那种急诊预约挂号
Tasha: And there's also the emergency appointment registration.
Tasha: 500块钱一个号
Tasha: 500 yuan per number.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 我给你调个电多的
Jake: I'll get you one with more power.
Alice: 急诊
Alice: Emergency.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm-hmm.
Alice: 急诊还得预约
Alice: You still need an appointment for emergency.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice: 都急诊了为什么还要预约呢
Alice: Why do you need an appointment for an emergency?
Tasha: 就是紧急急诊预约号
Tasha: It's for urgent emergency appointments.
Tasha: 500块一个人
Tasha: 500 yuan per person.
Jake: 嗯给你一个这个大的
Jake: Hmm, let me get you a big one.
Jake: 就是大的
Jake: A big one.
Alice: 暂时还没有遇到过急诊的情况
Alice: I haven't encountered an emergency situation yet.
Jake: 贵的
Jake: Expensive one.
Tasha: 我们学校
Tasha: At our school...
Tasha: 校医院挂号都一块钱
Tasha: Registration at the school hospital costs only 1 yuan.
Tasha: 你们学校也是是吧
Tasha: It’s the same at your school, right?
Alice: 因为有补助是吧嗯
Alice: Because of the subsidy, right? Yeah.
Lucia: 我们学校医院刚开始就只要5毛钱
Lucia: At our school hospital, it was just 0.5 yuan at first.
Jake: 换一个
Jake: Switch one.
Lucia: 后来加到两块钱
Lucia: 好过分啊
Lucia: So outrageous.
Tasha: 那那是一块钱我
Tasha: So that was 1 yuan for me...
Jake: 对要保证上面的灯一直是亮着的
Jake: Yes, you need to make sure the light on top stays on.
Jake: 他才能充
Jake: Then it can charge.
Alice: 张惠妹
Alice: A-Mei Zhang.
Tasha: 然后每次开的药都需要提个麻袋去
Tasha: And every time you get prescribed medicine, you need to bring a big bag.
Tasha: 去提是吧
Tasha: To carry it, right?
Tasha: 哈哈是吧
Tasha: Haha, right?
Lucia:  哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 对是的他给你开药都是10盒起开
Tasha: Yes, they give you at least 10 boxes of medicine each time.
Lucia: 没有这么夸张
Lucia: It’s not that exaggerated.
Tasha: 这没有那么夸张吗
Tasha: Isn’t it that exaggerated?
Tasha: 我每次
Tasha: Every time I...
Lucia: 你是使用了夸张的修辞手法吗
Lucia: Are you using exaggerated rhetoric?
Tasha: 哈哈没有使用夸张手法
Tasha: Haha, no exaggeration.
Tasha: 我比如说呃我最近有点感冒
Tasha: For example, if I say I have a cold recently,
Tasha: 他会给我开说哪里感冒
Tasha: he'll ask where exactly I'm feeling the cold.
Tasha: 你喉咙疼不疼
Tasha: He'll ask if my throat hurts.
Tasha: 我如果说喉咙疼
Tasha: If I say my throat hurts,
Tasha: 他会给我开喉咙疼的药
Tasha: he'll prescribe medication for a sore throat.
Tasha: 喷喉咙的药
Tasha: Medicine to spray on the throat.
Tasha: 感冒灵颗粒解毒胶囊
Tasha: Cold relief granules and detox capsules.
Tasha: 哈哈开到一盒一种药就要开两三盒
Tasha: Haha, he'll prescribe two or three boxes of each type of medicine.
Tasha: 那种可能就就不要钱吧
Tasha: Maybe they think those medicines are free.
Tasha: 然后他就一直开
Tasha: So he just keeps prescribing.
Jake: 头疼医脑
Jake: Treat the head for a headache.
Lucia: 头疼医全身
Lucia: Treat the whole body for a headache.
Jake: 嗯哈哈
Jake: Hmm, haha.
Alice: 今年没有抢到一张票
Alice: I didn't get a single ticket this year.
Jake: 抢什么票
Jake: What tickets?
Tasha: 抢什么票
Tasha: What tickets?
Alice: 演唱会的一张没抢到
Alice: I didn't get a single concert ticket.
Jake: 都有啥呀
Jake: What concerts are there?
Katrina:  我都找代抢了
Katrina: I even hired someone to get them for me.
Lucia:  让
Lucia: Let...
Alice: 啊
Alice: Huh?
Lucia: 让杨老板
Lucia: Let Jake...
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia:  用他的那些设备
Lucia: use his equipment.
Tasha: 设备帮你抢
Tasha: Use his equipment to help you get tickets.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha.
Alice: 啊可以吗
Alice: Ah, is that possible?
Tasha: 开启加速器
Tasha: Turn on the accelerator.
Katrina:  要搞一个Python脚本
Katrina: You need a Python script.
Lucia: 是因为他电脑多了
Lucia: Because he has so many computers.
Jake: 哈哈哈一样的
Jake: Haha, it's all the same.
Jake: 那你猜这台电脑
Jake: Guess what, this computer...
Jake: 就是这些电脑每一台都都是租的
Jake: all these computers are rented.
Jake: 然后租了十天
Jake: And rented for ten days.
Jake: 每一台多少钱
Jake: Guess how much each costs.
Jake: 你猜就是十天多少钱
Jake: Just guess how much for ten days.
Jake: 多少钱一台
Jake: How much for each?
Tasha: 多少钱一台多少钱
Tasha: How much, how much for each?
Lucia: 应该不会很贵吧
Lucia: It shouldn't be very expensive, right?
Jake: 给个数给个数字吧
Jake: Give me a number, a figure.
Lucia: 否则的话他就会买
Lucia: Otherwise, he'll just buy it.
Tasha: 一百块钱
Tasha: One hundred bucks.
Katrina:  我们学校竟然跳过这舞
Katrina: Our school actually danced this.
Jake: 差不多
Jake: About right.
Tasha: 我把我电脑借给你吧
Tasha: I'll lend you my computer.
Jake: 哈哈哈十天80啊
Jake: Hahaha, ten days for 80 bucks.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: What?
Lucia: 十天80
Lucia: Ten days for 80 bucks.
Jake: 十天80
Jake: Ten days for 80 bucks.
Tasha: 80一天
Tasha: 80 bucks a day.
Lucia: 8081天
Lucia: 80 bucks for a day?
Jake: 十天一个电脑
Jake: Ten days for a computer.
Jake: 一台电脑八十
Jake: A computer for 80 bucks.
Tasha: 10天
Tasha: For 10 days?
Alice: 一天8块钱吗
Alice: Is it 8 bucks a day?
Tasha: 一天才8块钱
Tasha: Only 8 bucks a day.
Jake: 一天才8块钱
Jake: Only 8 bucks a day.
Jake: 对一台电脑一天8块钱
Jake: Yeah, one computer for 8 bucks a day.
Jake: 可以不租了是吧
Jake: Can we stop renting it?
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 啊没有啊
Tasha: No, not yet.
Jake: 也可以租
Jake: We can still rent it.
Jake: 是吗我今天刷到这个
Jake: Really, I saw this today.
Katrina:  今天刷的这个5
Katrina: I saw this today too.
Tasha: 呃
Tasha: Uh.
Katrina:  是我们计算机艺术团的还是我们学校的
Katrina: Was it our computer art troupe or our school?
Tasha: 才80块钱10天
Tasha: Only 80 bucks for 10 days.
Katrina:  我学姐在杭州上班哈哈
Katrina: My senior works in Hangzhou, haha.
Lucia: 那我也在想居然
Lucia: I was also thinking, actually.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 这正在上班
Jake: She's working right now.
Tasha: 那我以后打游戏要不不买电脑了
Tasha: Then maybe I won't buy a computer for gaming anymore.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yeah.
Tasha: 去租电脑吧
Tasha: I'll just rent one.
Katrina:  这是他那年的毕业晚会
Katrina: This was from his graduation party that year.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia:  但是我觉得他租电脑可能没有那么高
Lucia: But I think renting a computer might not be that expensive.
Katrina:  他大四我大一
Katrina: He was a senior, I was a freshman.
Jake: 哦哦哦哦
Jake: Oh oh oh
Katrina:  居然
Katrina: Really?
Tasha: 哦垃圾电脑
Tasha: Oh, this garbage computer!
Jake: 居然我4年前就跳舞
Jake: I actually started dancing 4 years ago.
Katrina:  我4年前就跳过你
Katrina: I danced with you 4 years ago.
Jake: 你要跳舞吗哈哈哈
Jake: Do you want to dance? Hahaha
Katrina:  要跳舞吗哈哈
Katrina: Do you want to dance? Haha
Lucia: 我不知道
Lucia: I don't know.
Tasha: 弟弟得了一个怪病
Tasha: My brother got a strange illness.
Tasha: 要来北京治
Tasha: He needs to come to Beijing for treatment.
Tasha: 他在我们县医院治不好
Tasha: He can't be treated at our county hospital.
Tasha: 在扬州市医院治不好
Tasha: He can't be treated at Yangzhou Hospital.
Tasha: 在南京市医院也治不好
Tasha: He can't be treated at Nanjing Hospital either.
Tasha: 然后要来北京医院寻医
Tasha: So he has to come to a hospital in Beijing to seek treatment.
Alice: 他怎么了
Alice: What's wrong with him?
Tasha: 长不高
Tasha: He can't grow tall.
Jake: 长不高
Jake: He can't grow tall.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Katrina:  多大了
Katrina: How old is he?
Tasha: 12岁
Tasha: 12 years old.
Alice: 缺什么维生素还是什么
Alice: Is he lacking some vitamin or something?
Tasha: 可能吧
Tasha: Maybe.
Tasha: only  1米
Tasha: He's only 1 meter tall.
Alice: 1米1米大概
Alice: 1 meter, about 1 meter.
Jake: 1 米1米是多少
Jake: How much is 1 meter?
Katrina:  突变了吗
Katrina: Is it a mutation?
Alice: 这
Alice: This...
Tasha:  这
Tasha: This...
Jake: 我有卷尺
Jake: I have a tape measure.
Jake: 好哈哈
Jake: Alright, haha.
Tasha: 啊不用
Tasha: Oh, no need.
Katrina:  啊不用
Katrina: Oh, no need.
Katrina:  那确实有点啊
Katrina: That's indeed a bit...
Katrina:  12岁就这么点高
Katrina: Only this tall at 12 years old.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Katrina:  当然好着急
Katrina: Of course, it's worrying.
Katrina:  男生女生啊
Katrina: Is it a boy or a girl?
Tasha: 男生
Tasha: Boy.
Alice: 他弟弟哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Her brother, hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈妙啊
Jake: Hahaha, that's funny.
Katrina:  哦哦我没听见前面
Katrina: Oh, I didn't hear the first part.
Tasha: 我觉得可能是生他生的比较晚
Tasha: I think maybe he was born pretty late.
Katrina:  激素啊
Katrina: Hormones, huh?
Katrina:  就是我有一个我爸爸同事就是他
Katrina: So, my dad’s colleague, he...
Katrina:  他自己那叔叔就很矮
Katrina: His uncle is really short.
Katrina:  就是
Katrina: Like...
Katrina:  小时候就跟他儿子打那种什么促进
Katrina: When he was a kid, they gave his son some kind of...
Katrina:  骨骼发育的针
Katrina: Bone growth shots.
Katrina:  反正一年还要大几千块钱
Katrina: It cost several thousand yuan a year.
Katrina:  因为怕他儿子长不高
Katrina: Because they were afraid his son wouldn’t grow tall.
Katrina:  因为那叔叔也就一米六
Katrina: Since the uncle was only 1.6 meters.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 刚刚说要先来测骨相
Tasha: They said they need to check bone structure first.
Katrina:  对要测什么骨龄啊
Katrina: Yeah, check something like bone age.
Tasha: 看骨头还能不能再生长
Tasha: To see if the bones can still grow.
Katrina:  12岁应该还可以吧
Katrina: At 12, it should be possible, right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Alice: 是不是还会测什么骨缝
Alice: Do they also check for bone gaps?
Alice: 什么闭合酶之类的
Alice: Like, some closure enzyme or something?
Jake: 什么闭合酶之类的
Jake: Some closure enzyme or something?
Lucia: 对对要测
Katrina:  对对对要侧着
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, we need to measure sideways.
Lucia:  运动员也要测
Lucia: Athletes need to measure too.
Lucia:  那个
Lucia: That...
Lucia:  就是预测你接下来的身体发育情况
Lucia: It's to predict your future physical development.
Lucia:  小时候测过
Lucia: I did it when I was a kid.
Jake: 想当运动员
Jake: You wanted to be an athlete?
Lucia: 没有没有
Lucia: No, no.
Tasha: 当上了吗
Tasha: Did you become one?
Lucia: 不是不是
Lucia: No, no.
Lucia: 我其实不想当运动员
Lucia: I actually didn't want to be an athlete.
Lucia: 只是那会机缘巧合
Lucia: It just happened by chance.
Jake: 可以当运动员
Jake: You could be an athlete.
Jake: 但是不想当
Jake: But you don't want to.
Tasha: 还记得小时候我们学哦
Tasha: Remember when we were kids, we learned...
Tasha: 我上的班是什么国防班
Tasha: I was in some kind of defense class.
Tasha: 就是当兵当飞行员
Tasha: It was for becoming a soldier or a pilot.
Lucia: 哇好厉害呀
Lucia: Wow, that's impressive.
Tasha: 当时还有一批当飞行员的那个筛选
Tasha: Back then, there was a selection process for pilots.
Alice: 你弟弟的高度有大概吧
Alice: Your brother's height is about the same, right?
Tasha: 嗯当时还有一批当
Tasha: Hmm, at that time there was also a batch of
Tasha: 飞行员的筛选结果
Tasha: results for the pilot selection.
Tasha: 前一天他体检前
Tasha: The day before his medical exam,
Tasha: 我不小心把他耳朵给划破了
Tasha: I accidentally scratched his ear.
Lucia: 错了哈哈
Lucia: You messed up, haha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哦
Jake: Haha oh.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 飞不了了
Jake: He can't fly anymore.
Tasha: 我还在想完了他要是飞行员不通过
Tasha: I was thinking, if he doesn't pass the pilot exam,
Tasha: 会不会就全家要来找我麻烦
Tasha: will his entire family come to trouble me?
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈就是飞行员
Lucia: Haha, just a pilot.
Tasha: 就是飞行员身上不是不能有伤口吗
Tasha: Pilots can't have any wounds on their bodies, right?
Alice: 嗯对
Alice: Yeah, right.
Tasha: 啊结果他成绩没有考过
Tasha: Turns out he didn't pass the exam.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 虚惊一场
Jake: False alarm.
Lucia: 虚惊一场
Lucia: False alarm.
Lucia: 哈哈哈这不是我的问题首先
Lucia: Hahaha, it's not my fault, first of all.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 呃幸不是我的问题首先
Tasha: Ugh, luckily it's not my fault, first of all.
Jake: 对对对撇清关系撇清责任
Jake: Yeah, yeah, clear your name, clear your responsibility.
Alice: 飞行员还得看视力视力很重要
Alice: Pilots also need good eyesight, eyesight is very important.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Alice: 就我们那个女女的宇航员刘洋嘛
Alice: Like our female astronaut, Liu Yang.
Katrina:  嘘这太
Katrina: Shh, that's too...
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Katrina:  这个核心力量太吓人了
Katrina: Her core strength is really scary.
Alice: 他当时就是
Alice: Back then, she was...
Katrina:  什么时候能跳成这样啊
Katrina: When can I jump like that?
Jake: 可以就这个吧
Jake: This one will do.
Lucia: 他这个难度太高了
Lucia: The difficulty is too high.
Alice: 他现在就是
Alice: Now, she...
Jake: 哈哈哈对
Jake: Hahaha, right.
Alice: 跟我弟那个学校
Alice: She's in the same school as my brother.
Katrina:  这个是我开始玩的
Katrina: This is what I started playing with.
Jake: 确实很高哈
Jake: It's really high, huh?
Alice: 不对
Alice: No, that's not right.
Katrina:  我OK我关注up主
Katrina: I'm okay, I follow the uploader.
Lucia: 他好厉害
Lucia: He's amazing.
Katrina:  我去这就力量型爵士
Katrina: Wow, this is like power jazz.
Alice: 就是怎么说呢
Alice: Well, how should I put it...
Alice: 就他曾经上的那个学校
Alice: The school he used to attend.
Katrina:  就这样一下我脖子咔嚓一声哈哈
Katrina: Just like that, my neck made a cracking sound, haha.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Alice: 那个那个那个那个那个宇航员
Alice: That astronaut, that, that, that one.
Katrina:  嗯喜欢看一些大佬跳舞
Katrina: Yeah, I enjoy watching some pros dance.
Alice: 他原来就是
Alice: He used to...
Alice: 上学的时候就是参加选拔吗
Alice: When he was in school, he participated in the selection.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Alice: 就好多人被筛掉就是因为视力不过关
Alice: Many people were eliminated because of their poor eyesight.
Alice: 但是他当时视力就蛮好的
Alice: But his eyesight was quite good at that time.
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Katrina:  太厉害了
Katrina: That's awesome.
Tasha: 但是当飞行员视力都要很好
Tasha: But pilots need to have great eyesight.
Tasha: 然后身上没有伤口
Tasha: And no scars on their body.
Alice: 嗯是的对
Alice: Yeah, that's right.
Tasha: 然后好像还要转圈保持平衡
Tasha: They also need to spin around and maintain balance.
Tasha: 我也没有通过
Tasha: I didn't pass either.
Katrina:  跟那个偶像万万岁
Katrina: Like in that idol show, "Long Live the Idol."
Tasha: 对哦不好意思是飞行员我
Tasha: Oh yeah, sorry, I meant pilot.
Jake: 对宇航员
Jake: Yeah, astronaut.
Alice: 宇航员
Alice: Astronaut.
Katrina:  还有good time
Katrina: And "Good Time."
Jake: 飞行员就要这样
Jake: Pilots need to be like that.
Katrina:  呃就是这个
Katrina: Uh, like this.
Katrina:  还不如good time对吧
Katrina: Not as good as "Good Time," right?
Katrina:  然后猪猪侠我们排掉了
Katrina: And we eliminated "Pig Hero."
Tasha: 要不跳
Tasha: How about dancing?
Katrina:  排除的排吗
Katrina: Eliminated, right?
Tasha: yes OK
Tasha: Yes, okay.
Katrina:  排除了OK OK
Katrina: Eliminated, okay, okay.
Lucia: OK OK
Lucia: Okay, okay.
Jake: 哈哈哈哎呀我去
Jake: Hahaha, oh my gosh.
Lucia: 哎呦我刚也看了一个东西
Lucia: Oh, I just saw something too.
Alice: 中有你是吗
Alice: It includes you, right?
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈我就会一个动作
Tasha: Hahaha, I only know one move.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈是吧
Tasha: Hahaha, right?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina:  可以跳yes OK其实也
Katrina: You can dance to "Yes OK" too.
Jake: 对很重要
Jake: Yes, that's important.
Jake: 呵这是精华是吧
Jake: Ha, this is the essence, right?
Alice: 杨超越那个是啥呀
Alice: What's that about Yang Chaoyue?
Katrina:  差不多跟我高中跳那个
Katrina: It's almost like what I danced in high school.
Tasha: 呃我不知道哎
Tasha: Uh, I don't know.
Tasha: 创造101吗
Tasha: "Produce 101"?
Alice: 青春有你是谁啊
Alice: Who's in "Youth With You"?
Katrina:  我那两个分不清哼
Katrina: I can't tell those two shows apart.
Katrina:  那两个节目
Katrina: Those two shows.
Alice: 有没有男团
Alice: Are there boy groups?
Alice: 男团是啥
Alice: What's a boy group?
Katrina:  男团是那就是范丞丞他们出道
Katrina: The boy group is where Fan Chengcheng debuted.
Katrina:  那个是什么来着
Katrina: What was that called again?
Tasha: 什么也是什么
Tasha: What was it?
Tasha: 创造101吗
Tasha: "Produce 101"?
Tasha: 我不清楚了
Tasha: I'm not sure anymore.
Alice: 时代少年团是谁啊
Alice: Who's in "Teens in Times"?
Katrina:  少年团是直接公司出道的
Katrina: The boy group debuted directly from the company.
Katrina:  没有选秀那个
Katrina: No talent show involved.
Katrina:  TF的那个家族
Katrina: From the TF family.
Tasha: 你要收回来吗
Tasha: Are you going to take it back?
Jake: 没有我就玩
Jake: No, I'm just playing.
Alice: 我刚一折
Alice: I just folded it.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Tasha: 好你最多能挑出来多少米
Tasha: Okay, how many meters can you fold at most?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my gosh.
Tasha: 我居然也想到了这个无聊的游戏
Tasha: I can't believe I thought of this boring game too.
Jake: 他可能这个是这个
Jake: Maybe this is it.
Jake: 这东西的上限跟人关系不大
Jake: The limit of this thing isn't really related to the person.
Jake: 我感觉
Jake: I feel.
Tasha: 我我其实刚刚想的就是挑战一下
Tasha: Actually, I was just thinking about challenging it.
Tasha: 最高能折多少米
Tasha: To see how many meters I can fold at most.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Tasha: 好我们来猜一下最高还能折多少米
Tasha: Okay, let's guess how many meters we can fold.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Tasha: 谁能猜对
Tasha: Who can guess it right?
Jake: 呵呵呵把这全吃了
Jake: Haha, eat all of this.
Tasha: 谁要是猜错了就把这些全吃了好吧
Tasha: Whoever guesses wrong has to eat all of this, okay?
Jake: 那都全吃了
Jake: Then eat it all.
Tasha: 让我看一下现在多少米了
Tasha: Let me see how many meters it is now.
Jake: 那你看啥呀
Jake: What are you looking at?
Jake: 你要猜
Jake: You have to guess.
Jake: 现在一米4243
Jake: It's 1.4243 meters now.
Tasha: 好你猜多少
Tasha: Okay, what's your guess?
Jake: 我猜一米45
Jake: I guess 1.45 meters.
Tasha: 就是就就会折掉
Tasha: That means it'll break.
Tasha: 我们以那个为失败
Tasha: We'll consider that a failure.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Tasha: 让我赌一米6
Tasha: I'll bet 1.6 meters.
Alice: 我觉得你要完了哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: I think you're done for, hahaha.
Tasha: 啊啊那我要赌一米五
Tasha: Ah, then I'll bet 1.5 meters.
Jake: 我也觉得你要完了啊
Jake: I also think you're done for.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah
Alice: 啊那我要做一米五
Alice: Ah, then I'll bet 1.5 meters.
Jake: 那也差不多完了
Jake: That's almost done too.
Tasha: 你是一米多少
Tasha: What's your guess?
Alice: 哈哈哈 1米45
Alice: Hahaha, 1.45 meters.
Jake: 一米一米四五
Jake: 1.45 meters.
Tasha: 那我就赌一米六
Tasha: Then I'll bet 1.6 meters.
Jake: 那你想吃你就
Jake: If you want to eat, then
Alice: 没事反正哈哈
Alice: It's okay anyway, haha.
Jake: 吃吧你要不
Jake: Go ahead and eat if you want.
Tasha: 那我赌一米555吧
Tasha: Then I'll bet 1.555 meters.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 你要多少
Jake: What's your guess?
Tasha: 1米55
Tasha: 1.55 meters.
Jake: 一米55
Jake: 1.55 meters.
Alice: 1米55跟一米45差10公哈哈
Alice: 1.55 meters and 1.45 meters differ by 10 centimeters, haha.
Jake: 你你自己来你自己来一米55
Jake: You, you do it yourself, 1.55 meters.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake: 哈
Jake: Ha.
Alice: 因为它越长它这个
Alice: Because the longer it gets, this...
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake: 哇哦
Jake: Wow
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Alice: 你悄悄作一下弊
Alice: You secretly cheat a bit
Alice: 你可以把你的手往前伸一点
Alice: You can stretch your hand forward a bit
Alice: 但也伸不了多远
Alice: But it won't go very far
Tasha: 哎好了啊可恶仔
Tasha: Okay, fine, you pesky guy
Alice: 好了这才一米三多哈哈哈
Alice: Alright, it's only a bit over 1.3 meters, haha
Jake: 挺强的
Jake: Pretty strong
Katrina:  岳副歌跳了3遍
Katrina: He jumped the chorus three times
Katrina:  其实他新动作不是很多哎
Katrina: Actually, there aren't many new moves
Jake: 挺强挺强
Jake: Pretty strong, pretty strong
Alice: 没事
Alice: It's okay
Alice: 我给你
Alice: I'll give you
Alice: 感觉这玩意会割伤手
Alice: Feels like this thing could cut your hand
Jake: 嗯小心点
Jake: Hmm, be careful
Katrina:  其实难度不大
Katrina: Actually, it's not that difficult
Katrina:  我看了一下全是那个
Katrina: I looked, it's all the same
Alice: 慢慢的
Alice: Slowly
Katrina:  然后奔跑青春你还要再看一下吗
Katrina: And then, do you want to watch "Running Youth" again?
Alice:好
Alice: Sure
Alice: 有杠杆的感觉
Alice: Feels like there's leverage
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Hey
Alice: 没关系没关系
Alice: It's okay, it's okay
Katrina:  但是感觉只能跳一分钟
Katrina: But it feels like you can only jump for a minute
Alice: 哎呀拉地了哈哈
Alice: Oh no, it touched the ground, haha
Tasha: 啊哈哈别
Tasha: Ah, don't
Jake: 哈哈哈来吃开吃
Jake: Hahaha, come on, let's eat
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake: 这是用什么
Jake: What's this made of?
Jake: 这是加了什么别的材料吗
Jake: Did you add some other ingredients?
Jake: 除了面面粉面粉面粉鸡蛋没了
Jake: Besides flour, flour, flour, and eggs, nothing else?
Alice: 就糖
Alice: Just sugar
Tasha: 面粉鸡蛋
Tasha: Flour and eggs
Tasha: yes
Tasha: Yes
Jake: 嗯可以
Jake: Hmm, okay
Jake: 这什么曲子
Jake: What's this song?
Jake: 我去小孩吗
Jake: Are you kidding me, kids?
Jake: 这都
Jake: All of this
Katrina:  高中生
Katrina: High schoolers.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Alice: 我真没见过蘸白糖的吃法
Alice: I've never seen anyone dip it in white sugar.
Jake: 真的吗对那确实可能只有那一片
Jake: Really? Yeah, maybe it's only in that area.
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Alice: 嗯对
Alice: Yeah, right.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Alice: 但我们那有甜豆腐脑跟咸豆腐脑
Alice: But we have sweet tofu pudding and salty tofu pudding.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 那我们吃吃咸豆腐呢
Tasha: We eat the salty tofu, right?
Jake: 啊已经不记得了
Jake: Oh, I can't remember anymore.
Jake: 现在好像这什么店都能开
Jake: Nowadays, it seems like any kind of shop can open.
Jake: 已经不知道以前是什么味儿
Jake: I don't even remember what the old taste was like.
Jake: 因为有很多外地的人吧
Jake: Because there are a lot of people from other places, right?
Jake: 所以什么味儿都有
Jake: So, there are all kinds of flavors now.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake: 这一分半
Jake: This is one and a half minutes.
Katrina:  感觉跟那个跟3分的差不多
Katrina: Feels about the same as the three minutes one.
Katrina:  看下也是OK
Katrina: Looks okay too.
Jake: 这后面什么字
Jake: What's written here at the back?
Alice: 啥呀
Alice: What is it?
Jake: 这是一个团
Jake: It's a group.
Jake: 哦好吧
Jake: Oh, okay.
Tasha: 狗剩子不知道
Tasha: Gou Sheng doesn't know.
Alice: 谁是狗剩子
Alice: Who is Gou Sheng?
Jake: 我们后面也放一圈
Jake: Let's put a circle at the back too.
Jake: 呵呵放一个什么呢
Jake: Haha, what should we put?
Lucia: 因为是自己设计一个logo哈哈
Lucia: Because we're designing our own logo, haha.
Jake: 哈哈可以
Jake: Haha, that's cool.
Lucia: 因为每个练舞人就是就是那样
Lucia: Because every dancer just does that.
Tasha: 哈哈是吧
Tasha: Haha, right?
Lucia: 就会在后面放
Lucia: They'll just put it at the back.
Tasha: 不记得了
Tasha: I don't remember.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice: 坐你旁边吧
Alice: Sit next to you?
Lucia: 然后每次上完课之后
Lucia: And every time after class,
Lucia: 就会有人拿那个酷炫的那个有有
Lucia: someone would bring that cool stuff with them.
Lucia: 说什么云台的相机
Lucia: Talking about the camera on the gimbal.
Lucia: 然后给你录往前往后
Lucia: Then it can record you moving forward and backward.
Jake: 哦OK OK
Jake: Oh OK, OK.
Lucia: 然后录出那种视频的效果
Lucia: And it creates that video effect.
Tasha: 或者那个什么呃
Tasha: Or something like, um...
Katrina:  我要不发群里
Katrina: Should I post it in the group?
Katrina:  你们自己挑
Katrina: You guys can choose.
Katrina:  说服一下那个修硕
Katrina: Convince Shure.
Tasha: 啊他也要跳
Tasha: Ah, he's going to dance too.
Katrina:  哈哈拉进来呗
Katrina: Haha, let's bring him in.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina:  我最喜欢看男生跳女团舞了
Katrina: I love watching guys dance girl group dances.
Jake: 他可以跳
Jake: He can dance.
Jake: 我觉得可以
Jake: I think he can.
Katrina:  还可以我觉得
Katrina: I think he can too.
Alice: 我觉得跳起来没准比我们还
Alice: I think he might be even better than us.
Katrina:  对比我们更妖娆的有可能
Katrina: Right, maybe even more graceful than us.
Alice: 还还娇羞呢
Alice: And shy too.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Alice: 哈哈娇俏哈哈哈
Alice: Haha, so cute, haha.
Tasha: 那个什么
Tasha: Um, what...
Katrina:  这也不是很快吗
Katrina: Isn't this fast?
Tasha: afterlike afterlike
Tasha: Afterlike, Afterlike.
Katrina:  Afterlife那是不是有点难
Katrina: Afterlife, isn't that a bit hard?
Tasha: 有点难吗
Tasha: Is it hard?
Katrina:  嗯那是女团舞
Katrina: Hmm, it's a girl group dance.
Tasha: 我看好多男生在网上跳那个仿舞
Tasha: I've seen lots of guys dancing that online.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Tasha: 还有那个Dota
Tasha: And also that Dota one.
Katrina:  低头吗还是什么
Katrina: Looking down, or what?
Tasha: 到对头
Tasha: To the point.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Katrina:  低头那有点难那个
Katrina: Looking down is a bit hard.
Tasha: 那个有点难吗
Tasha: Is that hard?
Tasha: 他那个节奏很简单吧
Tasha: The rhythm is quite simple, right?
Katrina:  他那个跳不出那个牛津斯的感觉
Katrina: He can't pull off that Nujin style.
Katrina:  这还行是吧
Katrina: This is alright, right?
Katrina:  这多少 1分 43 还行
Katrina: How much is this? 1 minute 43, that's fine.
Tasha: afterlike
Tasha: Afterlike.
Katrina:  afterlike我看看啊
Katrina: Afterlike, let me see.
Alice:是不是该换水了
Alice: Is it time to change the water?
Katrina:  呜呜呜哎
Katrina: Ugh...
Katrina:  昨天昨天新换的
Katrina: We just changed it yesterday.
Katrina:  嗯afterlike好有意思
Katrina: Hmm, "afterlike" is so interesting.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha
Tasha: 哒哒哒哒
Tasha: Da da da da
Katrina:  张元英的团
Katrina: Jang Wonyoung's group.
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Katrina:  这有点难
Katrina: This is a bit difficult.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Tasha: 挑战张元英转圈舞那个
Tasha: Challenge Jang Wonyoung's spin dance.
Katrina:  哈
Katrina: Ha.
Jake: 哈哈哈可以
Jake: Hahaha, sure.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Katrina:  是真爱豆啊
Katrina: She's a true idol.
Katrina:  看张元英的
Katrina: Watch Jang Wonyoung's.
Lucia: 两天都经常跳
Lucia: She often dances every two days.
Lucia: 很有力量才
Lucia: With a lot of energy.
Lucia: 能跳出它这个效果来
Lucia: Only then can she achieve that effect.
Lucia: 我觉得我们这几天可能好不了
Lucia: I think we might not get it right these days.
Katrina:  呜啊啊
Katrina: Ugh.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 哈这要跳给谁看呢最终
Tasha: Who are we performing this for anyway in the end?
Jake: 呃呃呃
Jake: Uhh...
Lucia: 嗯呃我们
Lucia: Umm, us...
Katrina:  那也是OK吧
Katrina: That's OK too, right?
Jake: 相机哎
Jake: Camera, hey.
Lucia: 可我们还不是有什么九刀救无穷
Lucia: But we still have some infinite support.
Katrina:  虫子
Katrina: Bugs.
Jake: 呵呵呵对
Jake: Haha, right.
Lucia: 哈哈哈啊
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 九到正无穷
Jake: Nine to infinity.
Tasha: 啊这么可怕
Tasha: Ah, so scary.
Lucia: 这么可怕
Lucia: So scary.
Jake: 14亿全国人民
Jake: 1.4 billion people in the country.
Jake: 呵呵呵呵不
Jake: Hehehe, no...
Alice: 能不能是全球人民
Alice: Could it be the whole world?
Jake: 七十亿全球人民
Jake: 7 billion people worldwide.
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake: 七十亿全球人民呵
Jake: Seven billion people worldwide, huh.
Katrina:  帮我拿下手机薇薇
Katrina: Help me get my phone, Tasha.
Alice: 是这个吗
Alice: Is it this one?
Tasha: 看那个台舞吧
Tasha: Watch that dance show.
Alice: 塔莎你在吗
Alice: Tasha, are you there?
Tasha: yes you see you say
Tasha: Yes, you see, you say.
Jake: 像这个领域大概有有100个组
Jake: In this field, there are probably about 100 groups.
Jake: 100个组在做
Jake: 100 groups working on it.
Jake: 如果他们都用你们的这个数据的话
Jake: If they all use your data,
Tasha: 什么东西
Tasha: What?
Jake: 就至少是100个研究员
Jake: At least 100 researchers.
Jake: 他们要看你们跳舞
Jake: They have to watch you dance.
Jake: 对呵呵呵呵呵对
Jake: Yeah, hahaha, yeah.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 处理一下
Lucia: Handle it.
Jake: 对对对但是是但是你们就会跳舞吗
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, but can you guys dance?
Jake: 对没事
Jake: Yeah, no problem.
Lucia: 没事他不知道是我就行
Lucia: It's okay, as long as he doesn't know it's me.
Jake: 是是没问题
Jake: Yes, yes, no problem.
Lucia: 不知道是我就是
Lucia: He doesn't know it's me.
Lucia: 其实我拍的也无所谓
Lucia: Actually, it doesn't matter if I film it.
Lucia: 就算就算自打也不知道是咋回事
Lucia: Even if I get caught, they won't know what's going on.
Katrina:  lady Candle呀
Katrina: Lady Candle, right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Alice: 简直不敢相信我要是跳这个舞
Alice: I simply can't believe if I dance this,
Alice: 会有多扭曲
Alice: How twisted it would look.
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Damn.
Alice: 哈哈哈疯了吧
Alice: Hahaha, crazy, right?
Tasha: 疯了吧
Tasha: Crazy, right?
Katrina: 张元英他们团的舞你看着简单
Katrina: The dance of Jang Wonyoung's group looks simple,
Katrina: 好像没什么用力
Katrina: Like it doesn't take much effort,
Katrina: 但是你跳出来很丑
Katrina: But you look ugly when you do it.
Katrina: 你跳不出张元英那种感觉
Katrina: You can't pull off Jang Wonyoung's vibe.
Katrina: 好就他们团的舞
Katrina: Their group's dance,
Katrina: 我就我经常不知道怎么发
Katrina: I just, I often don't know how to do it.
Tasha: 那yes OK
Tasha: That yes, OK.
Tasha: 确实很简单啊
Tasha: It's actually pretty simple.
Alice: 来我家玩吧
Alice: Come over to my house and hang out.
Alice: 邀请你
Alice: I'm inviting you.
Tasha: 看能不能抢到医院的票
Tasha: Let's see if we can get tickets to the hospital.
Tasha: 我可能五一就要跟我妈妈在北京看病
Tasha: I might have to go to Beijing with my mom for a check-up during May Day.
Tasha: life
Alice: life
Katrina:  我发大群吧万一他们还要学
Katrina: I'll post it in the big group, just in case anyone else needs it.
Lucia: 剧组会不会跟我们一起跳
Lucia: Will the crew dance with us?
Jake: 可以跳可以跳
Jake: They can dance, they can dance.
Alice: 剧组是不是就最后一天会来
Alice: Is the crew coming on the last day?
Jake: 呃也不是周五吧
Jake: Uh, not Friday, right?
Jake: 周五他们上课啊
Jake: They have classes on Friday.
Alice: 今天周几周三
Alice: What day is it today? Wednesday?
Jake: 今天就会来两个
Jake: Only two will come today.
Jake: 上课打卡
Jake: Class check-in.
Jake: 呃就是紫藤唯一的女生她要打卡
Jake: Uh, the only girl in the group, she has to check in.
Jake: 他们实验室要打卡
Jake: Their lab has to check in.
Jake: 所以不太方便来
Jake: So it's not convenient for them to come.
Jake: 周末可以来
Jake: They can come on the weekend.
Jake: 周五周六周日
Jake: Friday, Saturday, Sunday.
Katrina:  奔跑的青春要分享吗
Katrina: Should we share the "Running Youth"?
Lucia: 要不分享一下让大家看一看
Lucia: How about sharing it so everyone can see?
Lucia: 然后觉得不过不好
Lucia: And if they don't like it, it's okay.
Lucia: 像现在这几个里面
Lucia: Out of these,
Lucia: 应该属于比较难的一个
Lucia: it's probably the hardest one.
Jake: 放到管家群
Jake: Post it in the butler group.
Jake: 管家一起跳就给你们开小车的
Jake: If the butlers join the dance, they'll drive you around.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha
Lucia: 也可以
Lucia: That works too.
Lucia: 欢迎
Lucia: Welcome.
Jake: 你们都做过了吗
Jake: Have you all done it?
Jake: 都做过了
Jake: All done?
Alice: 我没
Alice: I haven't.
Jake: 你还没有做哦
Jake: You haven't done it yet?
Jake: 今天给你
Jake: You'll get it today.
Jake: 今天还有一次
Jake: There's another one today.
Alice: 但我没快递
Alice: But I don't have the package.
Jake: 没关系今天该兜风了嘛
Jake: No worries, today is a good day for a ride.
Katrina:  该买嗯
Katrina: Time to buy, yeah.
Lucia: 我们如果要买东西的话
Lucia: If we want to buy something
Jake: 对是的
Jake: Yes, that's right.
Katrina:  OK这4个挑吧
Katrina: OK, let's choose from these four.
Lucia: P人的快乐时刻就是让他用帮忙决定的
Lucia: The happiest moment for P is when he decides to help.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Katrina:  投票吧
Katrina: Let's vote.
Lucia: 而且因为我这几年就是我我
Lucia: And because these past few years, like I...
Lucia: 我前两年就开始
Lucia: I started a couple of years ago...
Jake: 哦对就是这个
Jake: Oh, yes, that's it.
Lucia: 这个是我们
Lucia: This is for us...
Jake: 这个没有办法一起挑
Jake: We can't choose this together.
Katrina:  什么风格
Katrina: What style?
Jake: 对嗯
Jake: Yes, mm-hmm.
Katrina:  给我看看
Katrina: Show me.
Lucia: 这个是前前年的一个
Lucia: This is from the year before last.
Katrina:  啊我就说你有脂肪
Katrina: Ah, I was saying you have the figure for it.
Katrina:  感觉你很有这个气质
Katrina: You really have the vibe for it.
Lucia: 然后我之前学了一段时间hi-pop
Lucia: And then I learned hi-pop for a while.
Lucia: 但这几年都没怎么跳了
Lucia: But I haven't danced much these past few years.
Katrina:  有点偏民族
Katrina: It's a bit ethnic.
Lucia: 对对可能更现代舞一点
Lucia: Yes, yes, maybe more like modern dance.
Lucia: 因为我是没做过民族这个课
Lucia: Because I haven't taken any ethnic dance classes.
Lucia: 我们当时是教现代舞
Lucia: We were taught modern dance.
Lucia: 然后所以就我直接躺下去
Lucia: So I just lay down directly.
Lucia: 就是老师说你们要用到快点学了之后
Lucia: The teacher said we needed to learn it quickly.
Katrina:  嗯嗯嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
Lucia: 然后我就躺下
Lucia: So I lay down.
Katrina:  你这好有气质
Katrina: You have such a great aura.
Katrina:  这个这个
Katrina: This, this...
Katrina:  我有点跳不来
Katrina: I can't really dance it.
Katrina:  因为我感觉我没那么柔
Katrina: Because I don't feel that flexible.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one...
Lucia: 而且这个也不适合咱们这个场地
Lucia: And it's also not suitable for this venue.
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Katrina:  我们学校办金秋舞蹈时候
Katrina: When our school holds the Autumn Dance...
Katrina:  就全部都跳这种舞
Katrina: We all dance this kind of dance.
Alice: 可以坐我旁边吗
Alice: Can I sit next to you?
Katrina:  跳那种讲历史的那种舞
Katrina: We dance those historical dances.
Alice: 喜欢跟你在一块
Alice: I like being with you.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Jake: 哈哈哈哈可以可以
Jake: Hahaha, alright, sure.
Lucia: 这个我忘编的
Lucia: I forgot to choreograph this part.
Lucia: 我们老师让每个每个同学定
Lucia: Our teacher asked each of us...
Katrina:  你哦你自己编的
Katrina: Oh, you made it up yourself?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 我们老师让每个同学自己选一个音乐
Lucia: Our teacher asked each student to choose a piece of music.
Lucia: 然后编一段
Lucia: Then choreograph a segment.
Lucia: 然后但其实我只编了钱一分半
Lucia: But actually, I only choreographed the first minute and a half.
Lucia: 随后一分半我就胡乱舞蹈哈哈
Lucia: For the next minute and a half, I just danced randomly, haha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  心理素质好强啊
Katrina: Your mental fortitude is impressive.
Katrina:  居然能当人的面糊了
Katrina: You actually managed to wing it in front of people.
Lucia: 哈就有点有点推荐卡拉OK那个意思
Lucia: Haha, it's kind of like recommending karaoke.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 后面我就开始随意发挥
Lucia: Then I started improvising.
Lucia: 把前面的东西再抄一遍
Lucia: Just repeated the earlier stuff.
Jake: 可以freestyle
Jake: You can freestyle.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 不然没有人知道他原本是什么样的
Lucia: Otherwise, no one would know what it was supposed to be.
Katrina:  看一下如果这个只有1分多
Katrina: Let's see, if this is just over a minute...
Alice: 这个舞我来跳
Alice: I'll dance this part.
Alice: 不知道有多丑陋哈哈哈
Alice: Who knows how ugly it will be, hahaha.
Lucia: 因为疫情的时候就是
Lucia: Because during the pandemic...